I was inspired by voting because voting
allows you to be anything and anyone you
want to be bold is within the realm of
advanced family and that's what it's
supposed to be advanced family the name
voguing comes from vogue magazines the
movements that define the dance are
based on model poses from the fashion
publication Willy ninja who's called The
Godfather of voguing also drew
inspiration from martial arts ballet
gymnastics and even pantomimes and the
critically acclaimed documentary
appearances burning and it defines the
dance as an extension of throwing shade
instead of fighting two people would
sell their piece on the dance board so
whoever had the best moves would be
throwing the best shade during the 1970s
in Harlem houses were formed within the
larger dry ballroom scene these houses
serve as surrogate families primarily
for black and Latino queer youth each
house is led by a mother or father who
also serve as guides to the ballroom
community House of La Masia was the
first to form in the late 70s
other notable houses include the house
of extravaganza ninja Pandavas quarry
the house of Wong the house of Dupree
and there are many others in New York
and across the US while many of the
names came from the founders other
houses are named after designers like
Chanel and Saint Laurent numbers come
together to walk against one another in
various categories at elaborate balls
beyond the performance or throwing shade
these balls create a safe space for
empowerment and belonging whatever you
carry with you you leave it on that
floor
whether it's suffering from illness
whether it's suffering from
acceptance whether it's suffering from
not having a place to call your home
your house becomes your
after the AIDS epidemic in the 80s when
a large population of the ballroom
community was hit hard
the legendary balls and the houses that
organized them also became a place for
activism and awareness younger
generations of ogres can be seen taking
the stage at smaller keiki balls hosted
by the gay men's health crisis an
organization that advocates for the
prevention of AIDS it all started at
GMAC when Jimmy C was trying to figure
out how to get young people to come into
the building and so keiki balls began so
we could sort of attract them to come in
for services these balls serve as an
outlet for self-expression activism and
offer a resource for gay and trans youth
at risk of HIV homelessness abuse and
depression outside a ballroom culture
voguing has long been synonymous with
fashion and glamour it's often confused
for Madonna's co-opted version of the
dance form but it means so much more to
the community that made it dance is the
one thing that you can control with your
body that's something that's a being
that comes from you when you can take
anything that comes from you and gives
you a certain amount of being
comfortable in your own skin I think
that's great you know and that is
empowerment when you get up there when
you walk that ball and everyone's
cheering for you in that moment you feel
like everybody sees you it makes you
feel like you're not alone
[Music]
[Music]